Je peux te poser une question ?
Non.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que si avant même de poser ta question tu dis
"Est-ce que je peux te poser une question ?"
c’est que, de base, la question va complètement me faire chier
et je vais pas du tout avoir envie d’y
répondre.
Tu sortirais avec moi ?
Et voilà.
Non mais, imaginons on a 40 ans,
on a connu des petites histoires.
Au final, on se retrouve tous les
deux célibataires,
on se sent très seuls,
surtout toi.
Va chier.
Personne veut de nous, etcetera,
ça serait logique qu’on se mette ensemble, non ?
Ok, c’est quoi ton argument ?
Le Roi Lion.
Alors ça c’est un dessin animé,
c’est pas un argument.
Moi je suis un peu Simba si tu veux, et toi t’es Nala.
On est jeune, on s’amuse, la vie est belle,
et quand on sera vieux et que la vie nous aura réservé quelques coups durs,
on se rendra compte qu’on s’entend très bien
et qu’on est très bien ensemble parce qu’on se connait bien !
L’amour brille sous les étoiles.
Elton John.
Alors déjà, premièrement, je suis Simba.
Non, c'est moi Simba.
Mon père est mort, pas le tien, je suis Simba.
Ok, c’est toi Simba.
Deuxièmement, l’argument du
"on se met ensemble, parce qu’on se connait trop bien"
ben ça marche pas.
Au contraire, je te connais trop.
Par exemple je sais que tu te laves pas tous les jours
et ça, ça me dégoute.
Je change de vêtements tous les 4 jours,
ça sert strictement à rien d’être propre sous des vêtements sales.
T'es un porc.
Bon
imaginons la ville est détruite, en flamme,
je suis le seul mâle qui reste.
Ok, donc t’es Scar maintenant ?
Putain, complique pas, s’il te plait.
Est-ce que à ce moment-là, on pourrait envisager
de sortir ensemble ?
Mais moi je vois pas l’intérêt de se mettre ensemble.
Je passe déjà le plus clair de mon temps avec toi.
Disons que
je suis Timon et que t'es Pumba.
C'est toi Pumba.
Lequel de nous deux a été boulimique au lycée ?
Ok, c'est moi Pumba.
On est déjà un couple si tu veux.
A un détail près, c’est que nous ben on baise pas.
Un détail ouais.
Bon et imaginons, on a tous les deux quarante ans,
la planète est en ruines,
il n’y a plus aucune source de distraction,
je suis le seul mec encore en vie ici
et tu sais que tu ne verras plus aucun autre homme jusqu’à la fin de tes jours
et en plus, bonus, je fais un petit effort au niveau de l’hygiène.
Est-ce que dans ce cas de figure précis
on pourrait coucher ensemble ?
Non.
Putain.
Mais à la limite je pourrais te branler.
Ok, marché conclu.
Ta vie est si triste.
Hakuna Matata.